>> Laura: THIS IS LIKE THE
CHERRY ON THE ICE CREAM SUNDAE.
TELL US ABOUT THE BREAKING VERY
SAD MICHAEL AVENATTI NEWS.
SPEAK OF THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK ARRESTED STORMY
DANIELS' FORMER LAWYER ON
CHARGES OF EXTORTION THAT CLAIM
HE TRIED TO BLACKMAIL MIKEY INTO
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OR
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OH
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OE
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OW
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OS
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OG
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OI
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OT
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OO
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OR
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OL
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OA
PAYING HIS CLIENT $25 MILLION OE
DAMAGING ACCUSATIONS AGAINST
THEM.
IN A SEPARATE FEDERAL COMPLAINT
IN L.A., PROSECUTORS CLAIM HE
ENGAGED IN WIRE AND BANK FRAUD
AND EMBEZZLED FUNDS FROM HIS
CLIENTS.
>> Laura: I HAVE A QUESTION
HERE.
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE GREAT
DEMOCRATIC HOPE OF 202020 NOW?
>> YOU LOOK AT THE FIELD OF
DEMOCRATS RIGHT NOW AND AVENATTI
IS THE ONE WHO STANDS OUT.
>> PEOPLE WOULD BE FOOLISH TO
UNDERESTIMATE MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> SOMEONE WHO'S GOING TO GO
AFTER THE PRESIDENT AND FIGHT
HIM TOOTH AND NAIL.
>> Laura: THE MEDIA, CNN AND
MSNBC, SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF THE
WAY THEY ENABLED HIM.
THEY PROMOTED THIS CHARLATAN.
THE WAY HE WENT AFTER BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
HE WENT AFTER THIS NETWORK,
YOURS TRULY.